I know Ramona where somebody told me
you've been a very naughty boy this here
why don't you come over and jingle my
bells huh
hey everybody happy holidays we got our
flash midseason finale let's break it
down there were so many comic book
Easter eggs and we're finally getting
what looks like the trial of the flash
from the comics albeit with a little
twist
how many of you did a double-take and
remember this moment from the season 1
finale with him sitting in prison
they might actually pay this off now but
if you are finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a bunch of DC TV stuff
happening between now and when
everything comes back I'll explain that
at the end of the video there is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway but
we'll do Easter eggs as we go along
because there was a lot of comic book
stuff happening I'm amongst other
pop-culture references so number 10 the
thinker engineers a scenario whereby
he's able to yo ink berry and have a
meet at black steel Kaitlyn at the same
time just to keep team flash busy so it
took to the end of the episode to find
out why he did that exactly but it was
all on purpose like he wanted to divide
the resources of team flash so that
they'd be chasing their tail long enough
so that Barry wouldn't be thinking about
what Amunet black was doing with the new
dominant character whose metahuman
number 6 so remember there are 12 of
them total and this is only number 6
implying that he'll also be able to
enter other metahumans mines I think a
lot of that just depends on how good the
actors are that they bring on like it's
a really weird performance when you see
the dominant character go into thinker
mode like he reveals that it's actually
him inside that body and it's not the
person that Caitlin saved but number 9
you may have seen that deleted scene
that I posted earlier Barry and iris
come back from their honeymoon they drop
a whole bunch of Netflix stranger things
references 11 there's another spinal tap
reference and 11 the character from
stranger things but it's all just part
of the Ralf didney art during the
episode where he's like slowly coming
around and being less of a jerk but he's
the one that sets up that caitlin arc
number 8 by telling her the killer frost
is way cooler than she is so you know
make all the frost puns that you want
but I'm actually kind of glad that
they're not pairing them off as a
romantic couple because I feel like
they've done that to Caitlin too many
times
it's
like they have a little bit of chemistry
together but she still thinks he's kind
of a douchebag but a lot of you have
been asking if there is a drink named
after Cisco if there's like a vibe
version of the copy maybe by the end of
the season I don't think there is now
they only have the flash zoom pretty
much every evil speedster and now killer
frost so with the exception of Barry
it's almost like villains are the only
ones that get copies named after them
like the secret zoom version of the copy
is supposed to be so loaded with
caffeine that it's like being on crack
but number seven meet brainstorm so
Cisco gives him his comic-book name
there have been a couple different
versions of the character there's the
pre new 52 version and then there's the
new 52 version the funny thing about the
new 52 version is that he was actually a
mister terrific villain he actually
showed up during his brief solo title
the Silver Age version of the character
who flies around in a chair
interestingly enough kind of like the
thinker flies around in the chair was
able to use his mental abilities to turn
the other members of the Justice League
into drones with the exception of Batman
who was able to defeat him so it sounds
like for the time being the dominant
character is going to be around but as
the thinker and he'll be using his
telepathic abilities to physically
control other people and get them to do
what he wants so whereas before he was
sort of pulling the strings from behind
the scenes now he can do so in a more
literal way but obviously I think there
being six more metahumans from the bus
for them to uncover at some point he
will jump into a different body maybe
I'll do a separate video about it later
but it is possible because we got that
scene from the reverse-flash during the
crossover where he said I wonder what
base I'll be wearing the next time we
meet and we now know that Devo can jump
in other people's bodies is always
possible that before the end of the
season he could jump in to eobard
thawne's body but I don't know if
they'll take it that far but it's just
something to remember the way they bring
back lines like this house is bitchin
which they also did again at the end of
this episode it's almost like they say
that at least once per an episode this
season we'll have to see how many more
times they do that before everyone
figures out that Barry wrote down all
these things that are happening in the
future with these symbols but number six
I know you're all saying WTF is wally
how come he isn't helping out he was at
the wedding he took them all to safety
but if Joe came back then where did he
go
so they
drop Blue Valley again that place where
he originally came from the comics the
ginger version of the character where he
fought the starfish from outer space
that was still one of the best Easter
eggs the show has dropped all season Joe
explained that he went to Cambodia and
while there isn't any big comic book
Easter egg there he's probably just
trying to help people out as Kid Flash
using his powers to try and do as much
good as he can so it is a bit weird that
he's not around it'll be interesting to
see what happens when he comes back
because it sounds like the show needs to
find a more permanent place for him to
go because it does feel like he's being
underutilized he's one of the most
powerful characters that they have and
it almost feels like he's been riding
the bench so I think that will change
relatively soon number five the special
Speed Force prison Barry is able to
vibrate out faster than the human eye
can see so it seems like he's invisible
briefly so he does become a little bit
more powerful through the course of this
action but the real thing here is that
devote is trying to level him up so that
he's even more powerful when he takes
over his mind eventually which it seems
like he's going to try to do but for a
little while you do kind of wonder why
he's inside there and it seemed like he
was gonna turn into a much bigger thing
like they searched Devoe's house and
there was no trace of him but Joe and
Harrison wells didn't go anywhere into
this special room here
so this is real question about where
this space is I felt like it was gonna
turn into a bigger thing but we might
find out about that later this season
because it does seem pretty useful but
if he's walking around in Dominique's
body then maybe they won't go back there
for a while
then there's the question of what's
going to happen with the wife because
now we have the dead body we have the
trial so arguably she'll have to testify
at that trial so will she return home
and will they continue to use that lair
number for the chase through the air was
a lot of fun Barry is able to vibrate
fast enough so that the thinker's Clause
shock himself and the chair goes down
but again because of the big reveal at
the end of the episode it sounds like
the thinker knew that that was going to
happen and wanted to engineer that
scenario so that Barry would let his
guard down and stop searching for him so
for like a little while he needed Barry
to believe that he was dead so that he
could get him to go back to his
apartment so you just have to remember
that at every step along the way through
the episode Barry versus the thinker
Barry was doing
what the thinker wanted him to do so he
wanted this to all happen just to get to
this moment here where he could put
berry in a situation where he would be
sidelined but number three he had that
creepy moment where DeVos wife kisses
Dominic even though it's technically
devote it's in a different body they
have this weird connection but you get
this brief pause from her where she's
not totally sure about it but she gives
him the ring so she's acknowledging that
this is DeVoe but that look of
hesitation is just laying the seeds for
her possibly turning against DeVoe if he
goes off the rails like part of the idea
this season is that he might become so
powerful the team flash can't take him
down by themselves this is where we came
up with the cerebral inhibitor to use
against the Bo Oh at this point it's
just the concept I call this my thinking
cap just like their minds I've gotten
too small to handle at full capacity
mine's too small to deliver it can't
change all of that if it might wind up
taking the help of DeVos wife the one
person he trusts implicitly and the only
reason why she would turn against him is
if she thought she were doing that to
save him so he's jumping into all these
different bodies and his wife totally
loves him so she's in on the deal too
but at a certain point he might go from
crazy brilliant to just plain crazy and
that's when she tries to save him by
turning to team flash because of the big
twist during the crossover episode where
he couldn't kill the reverse-flash
that's right Barry Allen doesn't believe
in killing people so just remember that
as things get crazier and crazier that
the flash might wind up trying to save
DeVoe from himself with the help of
Davos wife but number two one of my
favorite crazy moments in the episode
was when Joe seemed like he was ready to
kill DeVoe on the spot if he thought
that Barry's life was in danger
there's no restraining order on earth
that would keep me from you if I thought
that Barry was in danger so just
remember that for later this season
usually there are characters that go off
the rails on team flash and for a little
while they made you think that it was
going to be the flash because he started
to go crazy no one believed him that
DeVoe was secretly the thinker but now
they do and he's the one at the end of
the episode that did not run he's trying
to do the smart thing by not running so
he's just showing that there's a better
way to solve certain problems they want
you to think that Joe might be the
person later this season to go fully off
the rails because he has a baby on the
way so he's extra protective of Cecile
and he's extra protective of Barry
but obviously the number one twist is
the whole trial of the flash and the
thinker overtaking Dominic's mind it was
actually a pretty cool scene watching
him put his mind into that body and it
almost looked like Speed Force energy
pulsing through those cables when it was
happening the same way the flash gives
off a certain color of lightning a lot
of you will remember that the trial of
the flash is a classic reverse flash
storyline where Barton was getting ready
to kill his fiancee Fiona Webb so he
snaps his neck but in doing so kills the
reverse-flash Barry has to stand trial
for it they take him to the 31st century
it becomes this big comic book storyline
they have to prove his innocence so
they'll have to find a way to use
Ralph's dib knees detective skills to
prove that that body was planted there
rather than revealed himself as the
flash they want to make you think he's
gonna have to reveal his identity but
the whole thing here is that Ralph did
me is like I need to be a better
detective so that's where he comes in
that's where he can really help team
flash out but like I said earlier
Barry's seeing himself in prison I'm a
hundred percent certain that that's how
they're gonna pay that off with this
trial that's going on right now well let
me know in the comments what do you
think of the big twist of the episode
and let me know if there's any Easter
eggs you spotted that I didn't mention
but what'll happen is there'll be a
bunch more bonus videos happening during
the off season there'll be some new
Titans that will probably drop because
they're still filming episode one of
that so those will be separate videos
but I'll do a trailer video for episode
ten in the morning we'll talk a little
bit more about future storylines and
Easter eggs from the trial of the flash
so say congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last video TB and our
lightning please private message me so I
can get your contact details there's a
new round in this video I'll just name
the winner when I post that trailer
video tomorrow but you can click here to
watch that deleted scene from the
episode and you can click here for my
new Deadpool 2 teaser trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight